there is no word that is more abused in
today's day and age than grifter maybe
science is another word that's abused
almost as much but grifter is this word
it's it's come into popularity over the
past few months and people use it to
impugn the motives of their political
adversaries very often the people who
are calling other people grifters are
the grift airiest people themselves
however there is a specific use of the
term grifter grifter means conman it
means as fraud it means a swindler and
there are frauds and there are swindlers
and Colin Kaepernick is one example but
the whole mainstream media political
establishment apparatus is another one
there the reason that you don't know
these kids names Haley mcenany called
them out for it finally I didn't with
this you know I was asked probably
twelve questions about the Confederate
flag this president focused on action
and I'm a little dismayed that I didn't
receive one question on the deaths that
we got in this country this weekend I
didn't receive one question about New
York City shootings doubling for the
third straight week and over the last
seven days shooting skyrocket by one
hundred forty two percent not one
question
I didn't received one question about
five children who were killed and I'll
leave you with this remark by a dad it
broke my heart a dad of an eight year
old lost in Atlanta this weekend they
say black lives matters you killed a
child she didn't do nothing to nobody
was his quote we need to be focused on
securing our streets making sure no
lives are lost because all black lives
matter that of David Doran and that of
this eight-year-old girl thank you thank
you mic drop walks off the set this is
what makes Kaylee mcenany so good at her
job
obviously she's articulate obviously she
makes our hearts go pitter-patter
obviously she's very clever but the key
here is she sees through the lies she
sees through the whole story the whole
con the whole fraud she sees right
through it cuts to the heart of it and
she waits to she knows how to how to
play a little stage craft so she gets to
the end of this long press briefing she
says okay you've all asked me a lot of
questions about Confederate flags you've
asked me questions about the symbol of a
country that hasn't existed in 150 years
that no one really cares about
and not one of you asked me about the
outrageous violence the shameful
violence on our streets all weekend you
should be ashamed of yourselves
goodbye a see you later Caitlin mcenany
isn't the only person realizing this she
might be one of the few people within
the political system that is
acknowledging this but people on the
streets get it you know there was a guy
who was in Atlanta Atlanta was the hub
of some of the worst violence over the
weekend and a bunch of black lives
matter supporters were holding hands and
performing there their political rituals
about the importance of black lives
matter in the radical social movement
and how we've got to overthrow the
system and blah blah blah and this guy
was off to the side the cameras were not
on him he said hey wait a second you
people are all frauds take a listen I
don't know who committed this crime but
believe me once we find out this person
will be brought to justice police
officer gunned it down three blacks and
injuring four Wilson High School will be
set on fire and every black leader every
community leader will be up here black
lives matters pants up black some
murdering blacks every 32 hours since
June I've been in this town all my life
I'm 56 years old I am afraid of being
shot and gunned down by a black again if
this was a white police officer shooting
killing three blacks people will be out
here the school will be on fire they
won't be coming for said I saw this
white police officer but because it's
black on black crime it is socially
acceptable but blacks matter talk to the
police it is a pulse and every 32 hours
since June blacks been murdering blacks
and y'all guys gotta do a better job
simple question why is it that the
mainstream media establishment is
worried about and not just worried I
mean spending all of their air time
focusing on the nine unarmed black men
who were killed by police officers last
year by the way some cases completely
defensively because unarmed doesn't mean
not dangerous but why
even say the number were six or nine
let's go all the way for all the nine
who were unarmed why are you focusing on
that and your privileges
those lives and you're saying that
matters but you're not privileged Inge
be many many many many many more people
who are killed in other instances of
crime well it's because one fits the
narrative and one does not fit the
narrow
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoice a software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description